[Musik]
denn
landet kann oder können muss deutschland
kann nach mehr zuwanderung verkraften
sie muss man dort besser kanalisiert
werden
[Musik]
es ist im prinzip unserer arbeit unser
haupt job ist es ja einfach gäste zu
beherbergen und da hat sich überhaupt
nichts geändert das ist eigentlich
geblieben nur dass die in andere
herkunft und für die leute natürlich
sehr viel unsicherheiten da sind aber
für uns sind es gäste und die werden
versorgt
[Musik]
wir verstehen die sprache mit ihr können
und ihre probleme nicht erzählen aber
man kann einfach positiv auf die leute
zugehen und das kriegt man dann auch
zurück
und dann haben sie dieselben taten das
haus sauber halten den vorschlag vor
[Musik]
und das muss man sich eben vorstellen
das ist jetzt der privatraum einer
familie vielleicht drei vier monaten das
ist natürlich
möglich aber es erwacht es verlangt von
den leuten ab
[Musik]
dort kann oder können muss sind ja so
laut so länder wie
die deutsche
[Musik]
alpin seitdem jetzt neun monaten die wir
jetzt insgesamt machen hatten wir einmal
dass sich zwei personen vernahmen
gestritten haben liegen nach
deutschland kann nach mehr zuwanderung
verkraften sie muss aber besser
kanalisiert wird
einfach hoffnungslos überlastet sie
können den mensch nicht mehr gerecht
werden da fängt also in jedem tag dienst
fängt quasi immer eine figur an und will
die transporte zu fahren und das mag
sich jemand der normalen bürojob hat er
seine normalen er akten liegen hat von
acht stunden tag x aus mal erwischt
worden einmal
um 4 uhr aufstehen und es da schon
anfang
einfach auch dass die leute da sind ist
schon für die polizei immer mit arbeit
verbunden die objektschutz maßnahmen die
dort auch vom ersten tag an notwendig
waren selbst verstrich tungen die nie in
betrieb gegangen sind haben wir immer
objekt
schutzmaßnahmen fahren müssen
es ist immer und immer wieder sind
politische versorgung sei man dann auf
dem rücken der polizei ausgetragen
die kollegen sind nicht gegen
einwanderung die kollegen sind nicht per
se gegen ausländer es geht einfach darum
dass diese ganze einwanderungspolitik im
letzten jahren ja viele viele löcher
hatte viele viele lücken und immer und
immer wieder muss die polizei diese
lücken aus bad
[Musik]